donc je devrais offrir ma
démission
mes seigneurs avec le congé de la maison je
me demande si vous me permettez d'offrir mes
sincères excuses à bonus Lister pour mon
manque de courtoisie en n'étant pas à ma place pour
répondre à sa question sur un sujet très
important au début  de questions
[Musique] au
cours des cinq années au cours desquelles
j'ai eu le privilège de répondre aux questions de
ce répartiteur au nom du
gouvernement, j'ai toujours cru que nous
devrions offrir les normes les plus
élevées possibles de courtoisie et de
respect en répondant au nom  du
gouvernement aux questions légitimes
de la législature et complètement
honteux n'avait pas été à ma place et
donc je vais offrir ma
démission
mais j'espère que la noble dame le
chef et le mobile du chef
auraient entendu la maison des excuses  depuis
votre mobile Bates est parfaitement
suffisant et il y a moi c'était un
manque de courtoisie mineur dont n'importe lequel d'entre nous peut être
coupable à l'occasion